[Musique]
les nominés dans la catégorie action
positive de l'année
bégué est à l'initiative
[Musique]
et
que
jeannot chalain c'est l'activité censé
donner de l'amour aux sdf tout
simplement on peut donner un peu de
manger peut donner à boire mais on peut
également discuter avec eux tu vois
[Musique]
j'aime quand le curseur
m
les eaux les clans ou s'effacer mendes a
été mis en route entre guillemets le 25
décembre
tu vois et puis depuis on a essayé deux
fois par mois et du coup une fois par
mois en général ces derniers dimanches
du mois on essaie de
de le faire avec des jeunes le noyau de
challenge et là tu vois
[Musique]
je l'appelle le chedi cadette
j'ai 30 ans je suis fouilles à l'aise et
je suis responsable technique au sein de
l'association émergence royal depuis
bientôt 12 ans je pratique la danse
traditionnelle et folklorique au sein de
cette association
donc je la pratique et moi même et
depuis bientôt six ans je initie les
jeunes à la danse traditionnelle et
folklorique de la matinée l'association
s'est implantée à dino en 2004 parce que
les membres était de 10,2 dillon et
parce qu'on voulait signer
bic de jonas et jeudi les difficiles des
jeunes qui n'avaient pas de métier de
son intérêt afin de leur expliquer
certaines valeurs bonjour je suis
laurent cipriani je suis l'organisateur
des conférences tedx à fort de france
depuis 2015 l'organisation de la
conférence tedx est véritablement donner
une opportunité à l'expression de
l'innovation technologique et sociétale
dans notre pays c'est à dire qu' il ya
des personnalités exceptionnelles qui
ont des parcours qui ont une expérience
de vie et ces personnalités là on a
l'occasion de les rencontrer au travers
des conférences tedx pour découvrir tout
le potentiel qui attend le pays ce qu'il
ya d'intéressant avec la conférence tedx
est qu'elle permet aussi de dépasser les
frontières sur internet tandis que c'est
une énorme qu'on énorme
comment dire visibilité c'est plusieurs
centaines de millions vu c'est des
dizaines de millions de personnes qui
suivent l'actualité de ces conférences
l'a donc l'idée c'est de ne surtout pas
raconter son histoire d'un point de vue
uniquement martiniquais et c'est de
justement donné de l'inspiration mais
qui pourra s'étendre un peu partout dans
le monde et ses salles exemple la
conférence tedx mon rôle au niveau du
tedx de préparer les speakers afin que
sur scène ils puissent être à la fois à
l'aise et qu'ils puissent délivrer les
messages tout en gérant leurs émotions
ok